[Applause]
it's already 228 and my opponent tonight
is them that's right I told you back in
episode 1 that them is an all-out
assault on us yes yes yes them them
hates us which is why the them's at
Viacom are crudely attempting to silence
my First Amendment right to have a TV
show it's not going to happen but just
in case I do go off the air I want to
pre respond to the stories that my
sources tell me are going to break over
the next few weeks here we go relax
hysterical mainstream media it was not a
big deal and totally constitutional when
Putin and Trump decided to wife swap
countries for a day totally normal
very sexy in an unexpected 5-4 decision
Supreme Court justice Ivanka cast the
deciding vote to reinstate forced
monogamy on women the medieval right of
prima nocta and that one thing where if
a dude buys you a cocktail you should
talk to him for at least a couple
minutes makes sense to me
what if Ted Cruz finally peeled back his
skin to reveal that he is a writhing
ball of earthworms doing a human
impression honestly I like him better
this way those are the stories coming
your way let's keep it moving posers if
I've learned anything from this show is
that there's no place for an outsider
conservative on the network that made
time traveling bong those libs can smoke
themselves into any situation so if for
some reason this pirated broadcast
frequency is shut down after tonight's
episode and that is a big big definitely
going to happen if mark my words
opposers the fight will continue yes
yes is what I formed the opposition I
assembled an unbreakable phalanx of
citizen journalists who will stand by my
side no matter what
Laura gray thanks for joining me are you
ready yes are you ready to fight by my
side oh yeah but Jordan I'm already gone
sorry not sorry I started a Christian
publishing company with a focus on
children's books kids are the most
susceptible to ideas so I'm going to
impregnate their minds and force them to
carry those ideas to term my first book
is called The Lion the Witch and the
border wall which by the way Narnia
totally paid for it already got blurbed
by Tucker Carlson he said love the book
hate that it was written by a woman Wow
you you wrote that really quickly I
cranked it out of my drive home last
night after soaking my tampon in monster
energy drink and just this morning I
pumped out two more the little engine
that couldn't get an abortion and one
fish two fish white fish white fish it's
already been disqualified from the
Caldecott award by Laura Timbo
the one man who will always be at my
side ready to fight yes I'm sorry Jordan
but I'm under house arrest
it's your you're covered in ankle
bracelets yeah they're my crime Rolexes
what did you do I did all of it you were
the the full buffet of lying crimes this
one's for faking my death to get out of
a parking ticket these two are for
extreme perjury which is when you lie
under oath before they even ask you a
question
and this one around my neck is just a
dog collar for when I try to pee past
the driveway but don't worry Jordan
house arrest is totally awesome it's
like prison but all my stuff is here
okay but once you're out of jail we're
going to keep fighting right
I don't know Jordan has a felon my
options will be pretty limited probably
just take a starter job in the white
house like in the mailroom or a
secretary of the EPA or I can always
pursue my childhood dream being a he-man
who rides a shark and knows magic anyway
I wish I could help Jordan but I got to
go pee past the driveway yeah okay Tim I
believe in you I guess Tim Nicole
Thurman you're standing with the
opposition right oh nice try but sorry
no Jordan yeah I'm getting out of here
faster than Bernie Sanders at a grocery
store when they tell them there's no
discount on bruised fruit I'm sorry
Jordan but it's time for me to get mine
okay and you know television is over
streaming is the future so I got my own
morning show on venmo yeah it's called
The Daily Show I'm pretty sure that name
is already taken who cares my daily show
is like the view but it's an app where
people just sends the same $25 back and
forth to each other it'll have like 10
times the viewers of cable and zero
white male host okay well congrats
Comilla be my intellectual powerhouse
surely you have not abandoned the fight
Jordan I'll always be with you in spirit
but physically I have been banished from
America banished can that even happen
anymore
it can Jordan but only if you tweet
something so bad so morally
reprehensible that the only safe place
for you is in a European cafe surrounded
by exiled Hollywood film directors I'm
keeping a seat warm for Woody Allen Oh
Kobe what are you gonna do I'm pulling a
Steve banning Jordan I'm going to live
amongst the authoritarians and whisper
up ideas in their hairy little dictator
ears
if it's time to encourage populism which
is another way of saying government that
doesn't scare white people have fine
enjoy Uruguay or whatever Erin Jackson
just sharp saviors of the first
amendment are sticking around right
hello Jordan
Erin is that that you you you look
different
I'm not Erin Jackson I'm Barron Jackson
Aaron's twin brother and with me is Tosh
sharp no relation to Josh did you want
to say anything okay okay we're heir to
Josh Aaron and Josh have passed but
don't worry they died as they lived
overdosing on cocaine aboard a circle
line cruise the boat was just passing
the Statue of Liberty and they yelled
hey you lonely old bitch ya idled mass
and then they died a memorial service
will be held in the unisex bathroom of
the soho Equinox they were not members
they were banned for reselling the free
weights on eBay what's it said none of
you are with me I'm all alone you know
what that's perfect
one man against all odds like Brave
Hearts or the King of Queens just the
way it was always meant to be this
conservative white male host is finally
in the minority the fight continued
opposers are there any three words more
exciting than click and subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it